We're just waiting on Dexter to show up.
So, we should be starting fairly soon.
Uh, but while we wait,
as you all know, this is going to be AI
that works. We've got a couple questions
that we can take while we're just
hanging out, uh, waiting for Dexter to
show up.
But, I think today's episode is going to
be really fun. We're going to start
doing some live coding. Uh, which
usually we go to whiteboards, we go all
these other things, but we're just going
to go straight into it.
So, I'll be back in a couple minutes,
but I'll see you in a second.
All right. Um, Dexter is actually having
some phone difficulties. His phone is
bricked um, as we have learned and he is
all the way over in Egypt right now. So,
international travel is um, exciting to
say the least.
But I think today's episode, we'll get
it kicked off. Hopefully Dexter can join
in a few. Uh and then as we go start,
we're just going to go right into the
coding side of it.
As we're doing this, let's start talking
about the most important thing, which is
if we're going to go and talk about
dates and LMS and time zones, how do we
actually make them work? There's a lot
of ambiguous questions that come out of
it. For example, I could say, let's go
meet up next Tuesday. And I think today
being Tuesday right now, at least on the
West Coast, it's unambiguously clear by
that I mean November the 18th instead of
November 11th, which is today or even
the Tuesday after that. On the other
hand, if we were yesterday on Monday and
we are saying let's meet up next
Tuesday, that almost probably means to
meet up on November 18th as well. But
yesterday if we had said let's meet up
next Saturday I could see how someone
could misinterpret that and say that
actually the sat upcoming Saturday
as opposed to the following. And as date
times happen it's really hard to get a
model to go and obey them. If your users
are in a different time zone than your
servers and you go and the user says
let's meet up at midnight tonight. the
LM can't possibly understand that if
you're normalizing all your time zones
to us like the UCT or your server's time
zone, the Pacific Coast or US East SWAT.
So, it's important to be really really
careful about how time zones make sense
because if you don't deal with dates and
times correctly, a chat thread that is
otherwise going perfectly can easily
mess up and give you the wrong
information. So to get started with
today's conversation, I'm just going to
go straight into screen sharing and
start going through code because I think
there's not much whiteboard to do here.
We just have to write some code and
prompt it a prompt our way to success.
And what's awesome about this problem,
it's actually not that hard to get
right.
So let me know if you have a hard time
seeing my screen. I'll try and zoom in.
Um, and as we go about it, we should
hopefully be good to go. So I've already
started a Python project here. Uh, but
I'm just going to
add BL pi
run CLI in it.
Cool.
And now we've got our project. As you go
about this, let's make a datetime
evaluator.
So the first thing to go here is to talk
about and
think about exactly how are we going to
actually build some of these functions.
So the first thing that we're going to
do is just say something like let's say
we have a function that's going to say
we're going to get a uh we're going to
extract relevant dates out of a
conversation
string and we'll do like for now we'll
just return a string array. We'll go
here and we'll say uh client open AI
GPT4 mini. I don't know why I like that
model. So I just do prompt that I like
because it's fast and cheap. Um, extract
all the dates from the following text.
Ctx
output format
roll user
text. So we got a really really basic
prompt and we'll go about this. And why
am I extracting dates first? Well, I
think the most important part is can I
have the model understand the dates?
Understanding dates within semantics is
even harder. But perhaps what I want the
model to do is just like normalize every
date that comes across some sentence in
a much easier to understand way. So
let's try and do that.
So what am I going to do here now? I'm
going to write a test case
dates
uh functions
extract date and then args
oops
uh text
and the text will be uh let's hang out
next Friday. So we'll do
relative dates.
We'll make a couple test cases off the
bat. Um,
we'll do this November 15th, 10:00 a.m.
Um,
time zone.
Uh, one second. Get rid of these time
zones here
at 6:00 p.m.
Cool.
And now as we go about this, let's think
about how we can go answer this question
really quickly.
Now when we go run this, let's just run
this prompt really quickly and see what
happens. So the model seems to
understand November 15th as a date. But
the first first question I'm getting is
okay, what about November 15th versus
11? How do we standardize date formats?
Well, this is where it starts to get a
little tricky. So let's just do this
really fast. We'll do year, month, date
over here. And then we'll return the
date.
And now when I do this, I get something
a lot more standardized than what I
could have done before because no matter
what happens, it will just convert stuff
to next Friday and everything else. So
let's run actually all the tests because
I don't want to just run this one test.
So absolute date it got right 115. Uh
date with time zone it got right. And
then relative date it did not understand
because next Friday doesn't mean
anything. Well there's a couple other
ways that we can do this. So we can say
like absolute date
relative date. And what you can do here
is like you can make this a string
uh
string at description. I think there's a
standardized timing format called uh
it's not like uh let me look this up
really fast and tell you what it is
timing
I think it's like there's a very
standard way to go do this
I think you're going to Okay.
So, we'll just try this. And now inside
of date, we're going to get a
boom. So, now the prompt is still very
simple. It's either going to be year,
month, date, which is absolute, or a
relative time.
One more thing about what this did. Let
me rerun all the tests.
again.
And this still works. It got us an
absolute date. This got next Friday.
Again, not very useful because next
Friday still can't be read in a good
way. So, I think there's a
uh use date use duration
strings like
uh so there's different ways to do this.
So for example, you could use a duration
string like this format. Let me ask you
what this format is. And now we get P7
days. Why does it do P7 days? Because
the model for some reason thinks that
this is a week from now. It's still not
understanding the problem. So let's
think about what we're really doing
here. The reason that this is struggling
is because no matter what we do, the
model isn't able to have context on what
the day it is today and how you respond
to a date in many different formats. So
for
>> like when you're like 10 minutes late.
>> It's very different than saying
something like let's hang out two days
from now
where this test should work with 100%
accuracy because this is a good way to
represent the data. P1D P2D it's very
easy to understand what you're doing
here. On the other hand a question like
next Friday is much more ambiguous and
this data model doesn't actually
represent this. Let's try this again.
>> Yo, Vipob, can you hear me?
>> Relative date
uh relative uh
days
and we can say
from
nearest
and then we can put like a we can put
some sort of like date type on here. So,
let's just say like string for now. And
then we can say relative
relative date
string
description.
So we can say is like we can say there's
a source
that comes from here. There's some
relative source and then given the
source here's the relative date string
that we have.
So if we start with this string and we
do this this one will still work. Oops.
with source
and now we'll go into a different
question that is if we're actually going
to go about and answer this question
what does this do relative days well
let's try and run this it still didn't
understand so let's try and add a source
date to this
source
let's say Monday uh November 10th uh
is the date that I'm going to give
And we'll add another optional parameter
into here called source
string right here
without
computation
reference
a refer and state.
Boom. Let's try running this query
really fast.
If we do this, it's still not working.
Let's try again.
I suspect it's because these types are
kind of confusing. So, let's just add a
more metadata here
and try running this now.
So, now it kind of understood. It was
able to go and say I want a relative
date and the date is going to be 4 days
from now. But it wasn't able to
understand that's using some source.
>> Hi Bob, turn your sound on. So, let me
pause one more time and try and think
again through this problem as we're
going to go think about this in real
time.
>> Oh, Dex, you're there. I can't hear you.
>> Dude, I've been here. Turn your sound
on.
>> Can you hear me? Can you hear me?
>> Yes, I can hear you now.
>> Fantastic.
>> Okay, you're back alive. Sorry, I wasn't
sure when you shut up.
>> Dude, you missed it. I said joke about
not understanding.
>> Oh. Hey,
>> guys.
>> Also, your your echo is now.
>> Oh,
>> are we good?
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yes, I can. I think we're good.
>> Amazing. Sorry for the interruption. I
completely derailed everything. Uh, my
god, do I have a story for you. But, uh,
I just, uh, the amount I went through to
get here. Oh, man. Anyways, back to
dates and times. I'm so excited. Keep
going what you were doing. I'll ask
questions. We'll do the thing.
>> Let's do the thing. Um, I'm so glad I'm
I switch screens. I was like, I suspect
Dexter is going to show up anytime now.
>> U, let me switch over really fast. Let
me find the window.
Cool. So, as you go about this problem,
let's first like reason about So, Dex,
I'll catch you up. I don't know where
where you're caught up to.
>> Uh, catch me up.
>> Okay. So, the problem is we want to go
ahead and answer questions like, "Let's
hang out next Friday. Let's hang out two
days from now. The meeting is on
November 15th. The meeting is at
November 15th on 6 p.m." And there's all
sorts of different semantics that get
tricky here.
>> Or like,
>> can you add another one that is like the
podcast is a 10 a.m. PT just like it is
every week? Oh, yeah.
>> 10 a.m. PT on Tuesday.
>> We'll see if Claude is uh smarter than
me.
Cool. So what's really interesting about
this is given all these date times,
what I find personally really
fascinating is there's so many different
data models that you can use to
represent all of these. Because for
example, saying something like the
podcast at 10:00 a.m. PT every Tuesday
is a funly fundamentally different
question than saying the meeting is on
November 15th because this usually
implies that there's a single
occurrence. This is a regular
reoccurring meeting. That means the year
is not very as relevant. Even the date
and everything is not relevant. In fact,
in order to know where the next when the
next podcast is, you have to know what
today is. Otherwise, you can't possibly
answer the question relative to the
user.
Um, and whereas everything else is kind
of anchored to a very very specific
date. So, I think the problem that most
people run into when they try using
dates with LLMs is as we're just seeing
here on all these test cases, there's no
single way to really represent them.
There they all are genuinely very very
different scenarios. What's your first
instinct decks before I go into like at
least what I have found works for this
kind of scenario?
Oh, did Dex die again? Dex is
disappeared. Uh, we'll bring him back in
a second. I suspect he's having internet
issues.
But at least for me, when I first think
about this, my instinct,
Welcome back, Dex, you are having
massive echo.
Hello. Can you hear me? There you go.
>> Okay, I'm muted. Did we good? Sorry.
>> You're going to have to
>> I had to leave and come back to switch
to my AirPods.
>> That's okay. I think you're gonna have
some echo based on the headphones you're
using, but that's totally fine.
But while we're here, as I go about this
and I explain the few edge cases that we
have, what's your first instinct to your
decks when you look at this and you're
like, I want to go ahead and go make
this slightly better. How would you
address the wide variety of date
questions that people might be asking
here?
>> Number one is inject today's date into
the prompt. Okay. So, you want to have
like a today in there.
Uh, so I'll call that source.
And for now, we'll just use Monday,
November 10th as our source everywhere.
What else? What else would you do?
>> Um, can you show me the extract dates,
the prompt?
>> Well, we'll update the prompt together
because I actually want your thoughts on
it. But I mean, like in terms like a I
guess here, I'll show it to you. This is
what we have. I have something very very
simple at least for now.
>> Ah okay.
>> Yes. So what is your what's your first
gut instinct on how you would solve like
the wide variety of dates that we have
here?
Uh, I don't I don't know. I mean, I
would want to just run one of these and
see what we get and then I would tell
you what needs to change.
>> How about we run all of them?
>> Okay, let it rip.
>> Run all of them and let's just look at
it. So, after running all of them,
here's what we've got. Absolute dates,
uh, which was absolute time. Absolute
dates was this one, I believe. Where'd
it go?
The meeting is on November 15th. I think
that detected it correctly. It detected
2025, 11:15. That worked.
Absolute time did not seem to work.
But that makes sense because like 10:00
a.m. PT every Tuesday. You can't really
extract a date from that. It's very hard
to at least.
Dates with time zones
is this one. Monday, November 15th at 6
p.m. That seems to work, but it didn't
get the time because we don't model the
time yet. Relative dates is this one.
Let's hang out Friday, which is 4 days
from Monday. P P P P P P P P P P P P P P
P P P P P P P D4.
And then relative date two days from now
is PD2.
>> Okay,
>> so some of it
>> some of it seems to be working, but I
find that like what is not recurrence
times. So, when you see that the
recurrence time isn't working, what's
your gut instinct?
>> Uh,
>> how do you prompt your way out of this
hell?
>> I would
my really naive without thinking too
much about it is I create a I create a
new class that is a recurring date.
Uh,
>> sure. Like why not?
>> Bronze string is fine. Okay. And maybe I
I also want to know like when is the
next one like next occurrence.
>> So what's interesting about the next
occurrence is technically if we have a
chron string we can compute it using
software.
>> Okay, fair.
>> Right. Like we don't actually need to go
do this. We need to take the chron
string and go proc it. I've actually
never used a chron string. I have no
idea what this means. So, we can just
try this and then let's try.
>> That's insane, by the way, that you've
never used a cron string. I do not
believe that.
>> I really have not. Is this correct? I
have no idea.
Um, I want to ask cursive to explain
this cron string to me.
>> And the time zone is wrong or it's it's
not time zone a crons are almost always
UTC, I think.
>> Um,
okay. That's interesting. Well, because
you run them on servers.
>> Yeah. Yes, I recognize that. But I did
not im immediately recognize that
because um for obvious reasons. What
does that cron string
mean? Let's just double check this
really fast. And if it's good, I'm just
going to put an assert on this. Oh, 10
a.m. every Tuesday. So every uh server
time.
>> Yeah. So the two is the day of week, the
last one. So it's zero is Sunday, one is
Monday.
>> So let's do it this way then. Uh let's
add a time zone
defaulted.
So let's add this in and see if this
works.
There we go. That looks a lot better. So
I think your instinct here is perfectly
spot on, which is you can always ask
yourself like what is a relative time
zone to every single date time that you
have? And every daytime can come in and
every there's like kind of like a uh
there's kind of like a variety of
questions you can do. But really the way
to handle dates very well is what you do
is for your use case you go ahead and
come out with a bunch of edge cases that
you really care about and that describes
a behavior that your users have. And for
each one of them you just go and make a
data model. And you notice the first
thing Dexter said is like oh this chron
string is going to be wrong because it's
not time zonaware. He's definitely right
on that. Well, we can solve that problem
by simply making it time zone aware by
putting an optional time zone. I'm just
saying default otherwise. And let's just
see what happens if we don't put in PT.
And I want to write another test case.
Uh, no time zone.
And let's get rid of PT and then see
what this does.
And what's interesting here is it time
zone is null here, which I think is
exactly what I want it to do because
it's not that I want it to be null. I
don't even want it to default to etc
because that's probably wrong. Uh
only if explicitly provided is probably
what the real thing I want is. And the
reason I [clears throat] want this is
because you can easily imagine like if
I'm a user, I'm not going to write 10
a.m. PT when I go talk into a chatbot.
I'm just going to write 10 a.m. every
Tuesday.
>> And I want the software is going to know
my time zone. the software should know
my time zone because client side I know
exactly what time zone I'm in when I'm
as accessing the software. So given that
or like when I'm on Google calendar,
Google calendar knows what time zone I'm
rendering as right now. So given that it
should be able to go ahead and say okay
if the time zone is null use the user's
time zone unless they have explicitly
passed in a time zone. And I don't even
think the user would be mad if you got
the wrong time zone there. If your
calendar shows ET, even if you're in PT,
and you said 10 a.m. every Tuesday, I
would expect it to do 10 a.m. ET every
Tuesday, not 10 a.m. PT, even though
that's the current time zone I'm in,
because the UI of what I'm looking at is
probably what I intend for it to go do.
It's kind of like a best guess effort.
But if I if I didn't recognize the fact
that chronzone like I initially did not
recognize that this was UTC or like
non-standard time um time then I would
just I wouldn't have even thought about
adding the time zone strength. But now
what I can is I can easily
convert every single recurring date into
an absolute date with just a simple data
transformation of applying a today and
look up the next time zone from a chron
string in a simple Python program.
Oops. So I can do something like main.py
types. Oops.
Import uh recurring date.
I can say def
uh next day
date recurring
date
to daytime. time.
Why is it so hard to type stuff out
today?
>> It's cuz you're not using code layer,
dude.
>> Probably to be honest. [laughter]
H Let me go write this down. Oh, I have
to go import this.
Craw equals
date dot
recurrence
convert
cron
to
daytime.
I don't know if this will actually work.
Uh, but I can figure this out. I'm sure
I can write a chatbt string to go
convert this for me and see how well to
go do this. And I can look up how to go
do this in a really easy way. Uh, and
I'll write I'll create I'll put a cursor
agent on this.
>> Yeah, this is not going to work.
>> Yeah, probably not
>> because time that's a format string. It
wants it to do hours and minutes
>> actually correct.
Make this function actually correct.
What I want to do is convert a cron time
string that I'm getting from an LLM into
a actual hard time stamp for the next
time stamp that would occur that matches
that cron string. And lastly, I also
want to make sure that I'm accommodating
for the fact that time zone is sometimes
not provided in the recurring date
string. So in that case, I just want to
default to the time zone that is going
to be passed in into the next day
function explicitly as well. But if the
recurring date has a explicit time zone,
then use that one.
I really like using voice uh to actually
get this thing to work. So I'm sure this
will work in the background and I will
have a new function pretty soon.
But I think the key part here is for
every single test case that you have, if
you're not writing each of these test
and thinking through it, even over here,
if I didn't think through PT versus
nonPT, I have no idea if this model is
actually going to do the right thing.
And I think this problem is actually
simple enough just like extracting dates
that you can actually do it purely with
like tiny models. You could probably use
GT5 Nano Gemini Flash. Most of those
models should just work. But what's
really important to here is if you if
dates are super sensitive to you because
perhaps you're doing contract review or
something else, every single date needs
to be normalized through some process.
Because if you just let the model try
and do the math of what the date is,
at least as of right now, it doesn't
work really well. And even if it does
look like it's going to work really
well, there's a lot of boundary
conditions which might fail. For
example, leap years in like February
28th, 29th that might make your off by
like 2 days from now be wrong in that
one year scenario. And you really,
really, really don't want that to
happen. If you're dealing with let's say
um if you're dealing with like end of
year conditions like January 3 uh
December 31st that's another edge case
that's just likely to fail. And while
these don't really matter the problem is
questions like doing things like two
months from now or five like five weeks
from now can make a huge difference on
what you actually need. And I think the
product that I've seen do this the best
is actually superhuman if for those of
you that haven't seen it. Um I'll show
you what I mean.
>> Oh it's great.
>> Exactly. And I think
>> you did this before LLMs.
>> Exactly. And I think that's really the
hardest part on this is this stuff which
is like let me share my screen again.
>> Oh, we're going to read all your emails.
>> Uh I have a You can see my u like for
example if I want to set up Oh,
>> no, not that one. If I want to set up
like a reminder for this uh
Thank you. I can just say next
remind me two hours
say like
>> H is the reminder. Yeah.
>> So you can say all sorts of things. You
can say like next week and it just kind
of works. You can say two weeks and it
just works. It just swaps it to Tuesday
and it does very rational things like it
says if I want to be reminded on Tuesday
by default I want to be reply into on
Tuesday at 8 a.m. So it's not even
saying just two days from now. It's like
two weeks from now is two weeks from now
exactly and it's going to be 8 a.m. on
that day. So, it's all actually doing a
lot of normalization for me no matter
what the user does. And what's
interesting about this is this is not
really
uh two weekends. It doesn't do that one.
Uh this weekend, if you do this weekend,
just say Saturday at 8 a.m. And you can
say all sorts of weird strings here, but
what's really important is it does a lot
of normalization for you. and this
autocomplete behavior this weekend at
8 p.m. It doesn't work. Saturday 8 there
you go. You can do like more specific
things and like as you can make strings
more constraint and what they're really
just doing here is they just have a
massive reax parser that just works in a
really easy way and it turns out for
daytimes this is probably the easiest
way to do this assuming you have some UI
interface as you're typing out the date.
But if you don't have that and you're
going to go leverage an LLM for this,
what you need to do is actually think
about the final end experience for the
user and what dates are really really uh
what I would say uh meaningful in the
end behavior. Have you seen a product in
the AI world do this really well,
Dexter? I personally have not.
>> Like I haven't seen
>> I like the superhuman one.
>> Yeah, right. The superhuman one works
beautifully for me. I've never had a
problem with it.
I'm trying to think. Um
>> I know I know contract review software
like a lot of B2B SAS that I've seen
work on this. They've actually done this
really well because they're reviewing
contracts and like RFPs and other things
all the time. And for them dates are
super critical. So what they're doing is
they're actually and it's very clear
what their use case is. They need
absolute dates. And the problem is the
users mention dates in all sorts of
formats but they are guaranteed that
they need absolute dates from every
single uh system. So like for example in
the case of like the recurrent state
that we're talking about what they would
want is let me share my screen again.
What they would really want in this
recurrence date time frame is actually
they'd want us to know hey tell me the
podcast every Tuesday for every for this
time frame and they always have a date
time of like here's a range of time
here's the end and start date of the
engagement give me every occurrence of
that and again we can imagine exactly
how there we go I guess it did something
here I don't actually know
>> you probably need to UV add some stuff
>> yeah I probably do uh and I can write
some
test cases for this as well. Maybe add
these two
uh and then what I found really
interesting for them at least is what
they would say is given a a start date
and end date of the full engagement give
every every occurrence of this and you
can easily see how if you have a
recurring date you can get every
engagement in this given a time frame
that matches that date time and that's
actually fairly easy to go do. The other
thing you can always do is you can
always ask more follow-up questions. So,
for example, in the case of the meeting
is on November 15th. If you know that
time is not provided,
then you can just make this optional.
And then if it doesn't exist, you can
just ask a follow-up question in your
chat window that says, "Here's a chat UI
that shows you a UI component. Here's
your date time, and we just don't have
the time, and we need you to supply
that." And you can either type that in
by chat or you can go enter it in
yourself using the UI component. Both of
those are fine ways of modifying day
times, but I actually think the most
interesting way of modifying data time
in a chat app is actually to integrate
something like superhuman where as
you're typing stuff out and it you're
doing some reddex string like two weeks
from now, it just it just swaps this out
just like if you're in cursor and you
start typing like at file and you start
mentioning something like uh sorry
uh main.py, it just autocompletes all
the files that exist and you can just
link to it. And this actually tells the
UI element to go inject that in. I think
day times are the the only real way to
use daytimes in a really random scenario
I think is that sort of approach kind of
like adding file context.
>> It's like parsing the user's intent into
something structured, some intermediate
representation that then can be
deterministically evaluated. And we we
talk about this for generating SQL
queries, for generating SVGs, for doing
all these things where the model's
actually probably not going to token for
token give you a really good
representation. Like if you say, "Hey,
give me every incurrence of this cron
for the next year." It's more likely to
get the cron tab, right? And so it's
like there's this thing in designing
like LLM between the LLM and the user in
either direction is like creating some
sort of intermediate thing that is easy
for the LM to write and is easy for
software to deterministically compile
into whatever the actual result is. Like
for SQL we have we talk about this all
the time is like you have don't have it
write the SQL statements because the
logic in SQL is nonlinear. But if the LM
writes actually the compiled SQL like
the a parse tree of like actually how
every like like token in the in the tree
interacts with every other token. The LM
can write it a lot better and then your
program can turn that back in decompile
the a into a SQL query to send to the
database engine to then recompile it
into an A and build a query plan on the
other side. Right.
>> Exactly. And like the second element of
this is actually like if the user is
saying that hey I want to have a podcast
every Tuesday at 10 a.m.
likely this cron string I save in my
database is going to be in UTC time. So
what's important is I have to remember
that this is UTC time and the user's
time zone is PT and every time I send
that string to the LM I need to convert
that UTC chron string to a PT time
string. I in fact want any timestamp
that I send to the LLM for that user to
always be automatically converted to PT
because then when the user says what's
going
>> but not by the LM so hardcoded. So like
if if I enter another time it's like
when was this file let's say part of
this time stamp thing is I want to
integrate Google Docs and part of that
is I'm going to integrate the last time
a file was modified by Google Docs so I
can go do this well I need to do another
time zone conversion because the user is
always going to say what's the file I
edited last night well how can the model
do that correctly if the model is
getting the time zone in UTC
it's just it has almost incomplete
information is sometimes under UTC
sometimes under PT
because the user is re referencing the
time zone relative to PT. It's virtually
impossible for the model to know what
last night means because it doesn't know
any better. It has complete incorrect
information.
>> Oh, last night is a tricky one. Yeah,
because if it's less than 24 hours, then
the time zones get really finicky.
>> Exactly. Exactly. And it gets even worse
than normal.
>> Yeah. I I sent you a whiteboard. Um, I
don't know if we want to use it, but
this this reminds me a lot of um
something that happens also in
internationalization.
>> Um, where like you want this really
strong uh like separation between
backend logic and client logic.
>> And so you have like your like DB and
then you have your like all your backend
logic.
I don't know why I made this so narrow.
Uh
and then it gets fetched by the front
end, right? And you have your front end
data layer
>> and then you have your like display
logic.
And when you do strings in a data in a
in an app that is internationalized,
this JSON object that comes down to the
front end is like instead of like
>> as close to the client as
>> close to the client as possible, you
have like you know you know button and
the text is like
>> uh you know I don't know I don't know
exactly like there's lots of different
ways to do it react.
>> It's like a lookup table basically. It
turns into like and
>> you know uh what is it like uh checkout
button or
dossubmit.
There's all kinds of weird like
syntactic stuff can do. But like under
the hood you're doing something like you
know lookup translation
for this like key basically.
And then in your source code, you have
this big like giant lookup table of like
what every string is in every language.
You have like enus
and then you have you know checkout
button
and then you have you know submit
and in English it's uh you know finalize
purchase or whatever it is right and
then in somewhere else down here you
have like you know uh ESP or whatever
like in like Spain Spanish right and
your checkout button submit is I don't
know how I don't know do you know any
Spanish. Should have picked a different
language.
>> I don't know how to say check out, but I
do know poito espanol.
>> Yeah. Okay, you get the idea, right? And
so like the front end logic should be
and so I think you can have the same
thing for times, right? Which is like,
you know,
label,
you know, user time and then it's like,
you know, 2025,
whatever your time stamp is. And maybe
it's 2025, you know, some ISO thing, but
maybe it's a Unix time stamp or
something else, right?
>> Exactly. I think it's also what's really
interesting about this is typically if
you think about how UIs are built, often
dates do live in UTC and then at the
very end, you just convert your datetime
to like you just do a datetime
conversion only on the display side.
Literally, not even the data front end
side. You just do like date to user
lookup time in the browser
>> and that's what you display.
>> And if you're someone like Google
calendar, go ahead. If you're someone
like Google calendar then like you
sometime have a setting of like here's
the times that I want to show as a part
of your data front end and then you
convert all the dates on the client side
to that but what ends up happening
>> go ahead
>> yeah go ahead no you go
>> no okay I was going to say the only
thing that's really happening here is
you have a new thing now which is your
LLM is part of your backend logic
and in this part of your backend logic
what's really interesting is you kind of
need the whatever the logic you do in
here needs to be the same logic as
you're doing in this one
because
these two are basically talking in the
same world. But the difference is the LM
and the display logic which is what the
user is interacting with and what the
logic and the computation and the
thoughts are happening off of are
linked. And I think that's what makes
this so tricky of a problem. Your code
is now split in two different worlds
where typically
>> and they're very far away from each
other. They're very far away from
Exactly. And there's a lot of plumbing
work you have to do to make this work
and feel right. And I think that's
really the bottleneck over here.
>> Yeah. There's also some like interesting
like math stuff happening here. I don't
know if you're on the the bucketing
challenges. If you go to the right a
little bit, if your question is
something like you know how many how
many events happened in the last day and
your day boundary is like over the data
set.
>> Exactly.
>> Like it becomes very tricky or like if
you want to bucket these events by day,
it's like depending on who the user is,
they have 20 in a day or they have 25 in
a day or they have 40 in a day.
So like it's not just literally showing
the timestamp in the UI. There's all
this like logic stuff that is dependent
on time and time zones and daylight
savings and all kinds of fun things.
>> And I think it's really interesting
because like for example like superhuman
makes an obvious choice which is if I
want to be reminded about an email, I
probably want it to happen at 8 a.m.
>> Like most people log into work, there's
like a 95 percentile chance that 8 a.m.
is a good enough reminder time for
emails to come in. So you just have a
really good default time. So what you
need to do as a user is you need to
think really hard about what is your
actual like boundary time for like where
the time stamps start making relative
sense for your problem space for your
domain and then you need to go
discretise it. Oh, dude. I was gonna say
before I got here, I was like, "We
should ask Brian about this." And
>> he was in the chat talking about it, and
I know had him on before, so I was like,
it's almost like a no-brainer to have
him come and answer his last few
thoughts.
>> Yeah. Nice to see you guys. Happy to
happy to answer whenever I can.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, now that Brian works at a applied
AI lab, he's definitely qualified expert
to share some uh share some thoughts
here.
I mean, I handle I handle a lot of this
stuff. Um, I think you guys are on the
right track, though. It's just like
almost interesting to treat the AI
almost as a user to the sense of like if
our users operating in like central time
zone will normalize everything that has
to deal with dates and times to central
time zone. Um, they're capable of of
reasoning around time zones, but usually
you just like don't want them to have
to,
>> you know.
>> Yeah.
work.
>> I think I view the LM as kind of like a
computation like engine of some kind and
you can choose where the gas goes to and
the gas going to time zone computation
is a waste of gas.
>> Yeah, it it's it's not a good use of uh
good use of your reasoning capabilities.
Um, but yeah, I think Dex is saying
saying something correct where like once
you have other things like memory or
bucketing that's based on time, that
also starts to get really challenging
because then you're starting to make cut
offs based on the user's time zone
within a system that might not operate
in the user's time zone.
>> So it just gets it gets hairy pretty
quickly.
>> I have a question, Brian. Does that mean
that to make this to make a system like
memory and everything else really work?
How do you deal with like in the case of
like calendars, every time I switch into
a different time zone, Google's like,
"Hey, do you want to change time zones
right now?" And I do because I obviously
want to while I'm in the new city, I
want to see my meetings in the time zone
relative to where I'm at. Do you do the
same thing in memories where you like
you take memory and then you realign
memories to the current time zone of the
user all of a sudden and renap
everything or does it kind of or for
latent memories that are really long
away you obviously don't have to do this
but for things that happened recently
let's say within the last week
>> feels like you probably should do
something
>> there's two dimensions here so you can
you you assign each memory bucket to a
time stamp right Um, and you do want to
shift the timestamp into the user's time
zone of when that bucket was like like
marked as. But, uh, and and you can also
recomputee the buckets based on the time
zones. For example, if you have a daily
memory bucket that what counts as the
day is going to change based on what
time zone you're in,
>> right?
>> Uh, I don't do that. I I mean, you
could. It just it's going to take a lot
more tokens to recomputee your entire
memory context, right? Uh, and I think
you hit it on the head. like it's not
really that important past the day like
you know 24 hours ago.
>> So we just
>> for you I think it's
>> for you I think it's like your memories
are never stored at greater than day
granularity. You're never storing things
at the hour granularity. So you're never
saying like you're doing one engagement
a day or one engagement. I mean I guess
if you have an email come in at 1:00
a.m. like did that
>> we definitely do more granular.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So we uh we go down to five
minutes now. So we have five minute
buckets and then hour buckets and then
uh day buckets. So it it gets crazy.
>> Yeah. Because I always I think the
reason that time I've seen be tricky at
least for like so for example the people
I know that work in the legal domain
>> um they have a problem like sometimes
lawyers will use the word tomorrow
>> and sometimes they'll be awake at like
1:00 a.m. talking about tomorrow.
>> Yeah.
>> And when I'm at 1:00 am talking about
tomorrow I usually mean after I wake up.
I do not mean actually tomorrow
>> or I rarely mean the day after, right?
It it's semantically relevant to what it
is right now because it was just today.
It's still today kind of in my brain.
>> Yeah. And and you'll have that same
issue with with agents because like it's
a semantics issue, not an infrastructure
one.
>> Yes.
>> Um but but yeah, we hit all of those
things. Um, there is an unhandled edge
case that I think Dex was pointing out.
It's like if you get sent an email at
like 1:00 a.m. I mean, recently we had
uh daily sales time, right? Like
[laughter]
>> another
>> Yeah, another like blow up your entire
infrastructure.
The worst project I am, the most
humbling project of my entire career was
doing this like hourly bucketing into
daily buckets for like fast reporting in
the future and handling it for multiple
users in a single account across time
zones and then figuring out what to do
the day before and after daylight
savings.
[laughter]
>> That's that's pretty much our memory
problem. Yeah,
>> I suspect the hardest problem here and
with time zones is one, time zones are
just hard even without AI. But what ends
up happening is when you toss an AI
element into this and your team hasn't
spent any time thinking about the nuance
of time zone relative to your domain
specifically or like date times or
relative dates at all, then users use
your product and say it doesn't work.
But in reality, you just haven't
configured it to work in it anyway. Like
it sounds like all this is solvable.
None of this stuff sounds untenable.
People just need to sit down, define
edge case, and just like understand
where the user going to expect it to
work and where does it break. And for
example, if it does break on daylight
savings times, I suspect your users will
forgive you.
>> But if it breaks on saying tomorrow,
>> like at 400 p.m. on a random day, the
user will probably be unforgiving on
that nature. And
>> and this is the nice part about
normalizing the time zone of the agent
to be the same as the user is that the
agent will also experience delight
savings time,
>> right? And so like it'll wake up an hour
later based on when the time is shifted.
>> And so like it might get the planning a
little bit wrong if there's like a weird
issue, but like overall it's going to
basically fix it the day of and it's
going to be fine.
>> Yeah, I guess that's true because if you
tell me remind me every Tuesday and then
daylight at 8 a.m. daylight savings
happen, it happens an hour earlier than
you expected or an hour later than you
expected. It's still almost correct is
the way I describe it.
>> Right. Uh who's sharing screen? Viv, you
want to go down to the right a little
bit? I just pasted an actual example of
of uh something that was happening in
one of our
>> uh one of our sessions.
>> Um I actually I sent this to a friend
because I was like, "This is super
sick." Right? So this is a friend of
mine who was just on a test account,
right? Um, and this is an example of
where actually part of our uh system
didn't have the right time zones. So
down here it has UTC time zones, right?
Because that was like a time for
database.
>> I'm going to highlight
>> this is just like a reasoning chain of
the of the model, right?
>> Okay.
>> Um, so he says, oh, this the agent's
like, okay, this is a UTC time stamp,
but I noticed that the agent or sorry
that the the user metadata is given in
PST, right? So, I should now be
operating in PST and converting things
into PST, which means that like he
thought the session was going to be was
an hour ago, but it's actually in an
hour,
>> you know,
>> and so you can see this down here where
he's actually able to reason through
this in real time. So, you do have some
leeway when you actually use these
models because like this is 4.5 sonnet
or a haiku by the way.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. This is like a model seizure.
>> [laughter]
>> and like having like a thinking too hard
like freaking out.
>> Well, but but in this case it actually
like it actually caught an error in our
systems where like I should have
returned a certain time stamp as a PST
time stamp and not a UTC time stamp and
it was able to actually get through that
and just like continue as normal and and
actually fix it for us basically.
>> Yeah. When I think about like an LM like
I think about this like the LM prompting
infrastructure and everything else like
how do you build this context correctly?
Like the right way to do this is
actually you as a developer just pass in
a datetime object in Python and somehow
like at some point the mo the prompt
just renders you just say I want to
render every datetime in this context as
PST no matter what everything is always
PST and you just don't think about it
and when the model spits out a daytime
object back it just spits out a daytime
object and you say no matter what
convert this to PST
>> and just always give me back PS or give
me back USC UCT time assuming that it's
PSC from the model at all points.
>> That's kind of what you want in like a
time zone. You want like an automatic
converter, I think, as a developer. And
if I were writing like a framework of
any kind, that's kind of what I would
build if I'm if I deal with dates a lot.
And dates are critical to my
infrastructure.
I just say this class always converts in
the right way, no matter what.
Yeah, you pretty much want to handle it
on your ser serialization layer to just
always be anything keyed to this user's
account gets normalized to their
accounts zone and that's stored
somewhere in the database.
>> And
>> um we also let the agent change the
account's time zone itself.
>> So for example like we had a student who
>> usually is in Pacific time but then they
went to India for a month,
>> right? And so you can like they'll tell
the agent this like hey you know I'm
going to India this month like we got to
change our schedule. Uh and the agent
can then change the time zone that's on
the account. Uh which means that all of
the stuff now is normalized to Indian
standard time right. Um it's an edge
case but it's in case you have users
that like move around time zones it's uh
it works.
>> That's actually really interesting where
the model can just like recognize it on
their own.
>> Yeah. Do you store the like event
recorded like what was the user's time
zone when the event was recorded
with each event?
No, we basically just like shift the the
memory buckets as well as like the event
ledger to be logged in the current time
zone. So like there there are some like
weird memory bucketing edge cases where
if you bucket a memory in this daily set
like this daily bucket and then you
shift the European time
>> maybe it shouldn't be in that bucket for
European time but we just don't go back
and recmp compute the entire thing.
>> Yeah because you're like again you're at
most error condition is like off by one
day
>> and in
>> not even but yeah
>> not yeah sorry like upper bound could be
at most off by one day if someone flew
to exactly the opposite side of the
international date line. fair
>> and did that like that's like the worst
case scenario but
>> and and they were on the flight working
on this thing like it it involves them
working on the flight while [laughter]
while magically then also flying and
then be like hey why didn't it work but
even in that scenario I can't imagine
the user being upset I think that's the
most important part it's like
understanding when will the user
actually be upset versus when can the
user understand
and like when can the user understand
that hey this is like a forgivable sin
kind of approach.
>> That's really cool. Thank you for
sharing the chat log. I thought this is
the fact that I think Haiku does this is
very indicative of kind of what we were
talking about earlier. It's like this is
not a hard problem.
>> No.
>> And if you do it right 90% of the time
in your software, if you make a mistake
once, the model can fix itself.
>> But if the model is doing this at every
single step,
>> it's just going to have a harder time
because you can just see the chat log
where it's doing this reasoning.
>> It's going to have to do that. It's it's
overhead on every interaction. And if
every interaction is like 5% more
overhead, that's just every interaction
has a likelihood of failure of 5% more.
And you don't want that cuz
>> And it's more expensive and it's slower.
>> Sure. Yes. That too. Yes. I forgot about
that part.
>> Right. [laughter]
>> Thankfully, Haiku is crazy fast. I mean,
this reasoning chain took, I think,
under a second to get back to us
streaming.
>> Yeah. Then I guess that that explains
it.
I think it just goes back to the fact of
like if you do a modic amount of work to
go correct this for from your at the
serialization and just do it the right
way
>> so models don't have to think then it
will these systems will just work.
>> Yeah.
>> But if you don't do it the right way
then like your app probably won't work
especially datetimes are a common part
of interactions. For example, like if
you're doing a data analysis job of any
kind,
if you're doing a data analysis job,
you're basically screwed if you don't
handle time zones correctly and like
you're doing time series data. Like of
course that thing's not working because
your users are talking relative time
zones and you're not processing them
correctly. You got to stand. And then
Elizabeth brought up a good point of
like use ISO standardization. It's a
really good technique, but it fails for
relative time. So you have to use like
some sort of relative time zone
technique and for that you usually need
I is that what you guys do Brian? Do you
guys have custom data models that
represent like relative time zones like
>> like recurrence or something else? How
do you deal with those kinds of systems
in your in your world?
>> We just store everything in ETC and then
normalize it on the way out of the API.
>> Got it. And then uh but how do you model
recurrence or do you have recurrence?
I'm not sure I followed the question
>> like like uh like hey this event happens
every Tuesday at XYZ time like recurring
events.
>> Oh
>> uh yeah we don't really have like a a so
we have a calendar application.
>> Um but there's not like a every two
weeks kind of thing. We just kind of let
the model decide like okay let's make
the next event the next event the next
event and the recurrence also gets
somewhat structured in memory as well as
like a user preference.
>> Um
>> got it. the combination of the two tends
to work. But I would love I would love
to like if someone's building a very
like SDK,
you know, SDKable calendar app that just
handles these things, we'd love to use
it.
>> That's funny. Yeah.
>> Like built for an agent because then we
have to build it ourselves.
>> We have uh we tried building recurrence
into our previous data model. Uh we
built a Slack competitor before we were
building BAML
>> and we did build recurrence into the
calendar app that we had integrated and
I can just tell you that it is not fun
to data model.
>> The Google calendar API or the data it
gives you for recurrence is not fun. You
do not want it uh at all because
recurrence is
people do recurrence and then they
realize that hey what people want to do
is they want to both edit every element
in the recurrence chain and they also
sometime want to edit individual
elements say this one recurrence is
going to change
>> and we're and there's all sorts of
modification you have to it's just not
fun way.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And if you edit and move it one
day forward and you say edit all future
events, that actually means move all the
future events one day forward so they're
all still a week apart. Or it's like no,
I just wanted to update the description
on all the future ones but leave them on
the same date.
>> Yeah, exactly. So it's really tricky how
you have to go do that.
>> I have not uh been confident enough to
give an AI the uh the full capabilities
of doing that and trusting it to do it
accurately. And honestly, that's
probably the best thing to do where it's
like, hey, instead of letting your user
shoot themselves in the foot with a
broken feature, just don't like if you
don't have confidence that you can go
ship it, just don't do it.
>> And like
>> you build some UI to make your users
interact with us. Like, hey, build a
calendar app UI only interaction for
recurrence.
>> Agent just can't do this. Sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we'll see.
>> But yeah, sorry to crash the session.
Figured it'd be interesting to share,
but um I saw you on Twitter. I was like,
I should talk about this. Uh this is
hilarious. I think the chat thread is a
perfect articulation of what we were
talking about today happening in real
time in a real production app. Uh so I
think it's good that it uh echoes the
same sentiment.
>> Cool. Best luck in the rest of the rest
of the workshop.
>> Oh, I think we're gonna pretty soon we
got a hard stop today. [laughter]
>> Okay.
>> Um Dexter, anything else you want to
share for anyone else that's interested?
We'll go post some of the learnings
here. We'll include Brian's chat log.
So, I think it'd be fun for people to go
read. Uh, but this is AI that works.
Today we talked about dates, times,
LLMs. I think next week we're going to
do another fun episode that Dexter might
have in mind. So, we'll see how that
goes.
>> It's a It's a surprise. It's gonna be
fun.
>> Cool. All right. Good seeing everyone.
>> Thanks, everybody.
>> Bye, everyone.